good evening despite recommendations to
stay home this holiday millions are
still attempting to see their family
thanks for joining us here at five i'm
denise feldes and i'm brian loftis today
is usually one of the busiest travel
days of the entire year many families
are staying home but some continue to be
on the move joe moeller spoke to
travelers
he's live at silverado ranch boulevard
and i-15 with more on why they chose to
travel
joe
if you've traveled the day before
thanksgiving you know it can be a pain
but i want to give you a live look at
the 15 here this evening take a look
traffic is moving smoothly and it is not
bumper to bumper like we have seen in
the years past people who were driving
in and out of
las vegas today say they were happy and
also
we surprised catch any traffic going
here and
we actually didn't expect to be at this
location at this hour
we interviewed luis there at 7 magic
mountains which was quite busy today
triple a expects a 10 percent drop in
travel this year around 47 million are
expected to travel
by car this weekend due to coveted cases
climbing it is recommended
in our state for people to stay home
however states like california
have travel restrictions in place about
two and a half million are expected to
fly mccarron was steady today but
nothing as busy as years past
travelers we talked to at the airport
say they do feel safe flying
we got there two hours early and it was
fine like everyone in the airport stayed
apart from each other and
we had our middle seat it was perfect
mccarran is stepping up safety protocols
they are limiting the number of people
inside to ticketed passengers only
they are recommending getting to the
airport early as some safety measures
may take people longer now back out here
live you're taking another live look
here at the 15 at this hour
also happening here during the
thanksgiving travel period is
nevada highway patrol along with
california highway patrol they're both
working together to step up enforcement
today alone
here in nevada 470 citations were issued
that was as of
an hour ago and that will continue
through the evening reporting live joe
mullen 8 news